okay so the topic of this video is the
energy that exists within an ecosystem
so let's get started
so when we begin our discussion we
should talk about the components of an
eco system let's start with the
producers
after all they form the basis of the
energy within an ecosystem
you know this coral reef here is powered
by the photosynthetic corals that you
see this particular wetland is powered
by the photosynthetic plants that you
see now this desert right here is
powered by the photosynthetic plant so
let's start with the producer so the
producers are the autotrophs in an
ecosystem those that are able to perform
photosynthesis in order to make sugars
you know we need three basic ingredients
water carbon dioxide and sunlight in
order for the autotrophs to do
photosynthesis and then they will
produce some oxygen waste but more
importantly they produce glucose that's
the prize of photosynthesis that's why
they're called producers this glucose is
the energy that they produced for the
ecosystem so a lesser-known example of a
producer are the chemo tropes and these
are the bacteria that actually feed upon
the minerals being released out of the
hydrothermal vents like like the ones
you see in this picture you see the
smoke billowing out of the cracks well
in that smoke are minerals that bacteria
will feed upon which they then are the
basis of their ecosystems but most the
time when we say producers were
referring to the photosynthetic
autotrophs like plants
so also in an ecosystem are the
consumers the heterotrophs those that
actually consuming eat others for energy
you know here's a list of some of the
various types of consumers you know the
lion here represents a carnivore as it's
a meat-eater here we have some elk
grazing on grasses while they're
herbivores they're plant eaters you know
bears are kind of a classic example of
an omnivore I'm neva Z both plants and
animals later on we'll talk about the
detritivores and how they eat organic
matter versus the sapa fights and how
they absorb organic matter so these are
coming later on in the presentation
okay so now I want to talk about the
trophic levels in an ecosystem or the
feeding levels here you see a food chain
with five feeding levels five trophic
levels the plant is one the grasshopper
tuna the mouse is three the snake is 4
the hawk is level five an trophic levels
show how organisms feed throughout an
ecosystem and so in this food chain you
can see a producer in the form of the
tree and you can see various consumers
now often in a food chain decomposers
are not diagrammed and illustrated and
I'll talk about why that is in a little
bit but sometimes you might see them and
one thing to mention is that when energy
is passed from one trophic level to the
next it's actually passed at a fairly
inefficient level about 10% so let's say
here we have our producer the tree the
tree the plant and because it's the
producer it will produce 100% of the
energy for this particular environment
but as the energy moves from the plant
to the grasshopper because the
grasshopper is consuming leaves and
fruits from the plant it's estimated
that only about 10% of the energy level
moves up to the next trophic level so
when the mice come along and eat the
grasshoppers they only get about 10% of
what the grasshoppers head which is 1%
of what the plant made and now when we
go to the snake only about 0.1 percent
of the energy that was created by the
plant ever makes its way to the snake
and when we get to the hawk it's even
less 0.01 percent of the energy that the
plants made will trickle upward to the
hawk so you can see energy is passed
at a pretty inefficient level well where
did the other 90% of the energy go well
it's used by the organism while they're
alive and quite often in warm-blooded
animals it's it's lost as heat but this
is why energy is passed at a pretty
inefficient level only about 10 percent
and so this is also also explains why a
food chain will typically only have four
five six trophic levels it's very rare
to see a food
Chane with seven eight nine ten eleven
twelve trophic levels because when you
get to the top there's often does not
enough edgy to sustain the organism at
the top you know if I ask you this
question why are there fewer Hawks in a
forest than the number of grasshoppers
well this picture this diagram here
shows it nice way I think there's just
not enough energy to sustain a large
population of Hawks compared to the
grasshoppers the grasshopper lower on
the food chain so they have more energy
available to themselves
so let's look at food chains in a little
more detail starting at the bottom we
have the first trophic level which is
going to be a producer of some kind now
typically we're going to talk about the
autotrophs that perform photosynthesis
they use carbon dioxide water and
sunlight to produce sugars like glucose
and so when we say that these are at the
bottom of the food chain please do not
misinterpret that and think that oh
they're at the bottom they're not
important it's the exact opposite they
are the most important trophic level in
a food chain because they're the
foundation they produce all the energy
that the life above them depends upon
and so typically these are the plants
the most common everyday type of
producer that we think of but they're
not the only one you know apple trees
you know pretty common plant that
produces energy for the ecosystem but
there's also an algae that you know live
in ponds and rivers and lakes and
streams and they do photosynthesis and
here we have ocean kelp a kelp forest
that does photosynthesis and even some
types of bacteria are green and will do
photosynthesis in their environments and
so these are the producers the
photosynthetic autotrophs when we move
up to the second trophic level we call
these the primary consumer so be careful
it's trophic level number two but
consumer number one because when we look
at the first trophic level that's a
producer so now we've come to the first
consumer and like the like the diagram
shows these are the consumers that feed
upon the lower level which would be the
plants the producers and so these are
typically called the herbivores in a in
a food chain you know here we have a
mouse that is eating seeds you know a
great example of an herbivore
there we have elk grazing on grasses
again good example of the elk being
herbivores and lastly here we have score
a squirrel feeding upon nuts from a tree
so again these are good examples of a
primary consumer or also herbivores
okay so when we move up to the next
trophic level the third overall trophic
level we come to the secondary consumer
it's the second consumer even though
it's the third overall level and like
the name implies and like the diagram
implies the secondary consumer will feed
upon the level beneath them the primary
consumers so at this level we start to
see the introduction of omnivores into
the food chain
I'm Devore's are animals that will eat
both plants and animals and we also see
some small carnivores at this point in
the food chain as well so here we have
the for instance a spider eating an
insect here we have for example a duck
you know eating a frog you know here we
have another example of you know pretty
low in the food chain of a larger lizard
eating a smaller lizard so we have
examples of carnivores and examples of
omnivores at this point in the food
chain well as we come to the fourth
trophic level this would be the third
consumer in the word for third is
tertiary so now we have the third
consumer the tertiary consumer feeding
upon the level beneath it which would be
the secondary consumers as we get higher
and higher on the food chain this is
where we start to see you know the
larger carnivore is the larger omnivores
in in an environment so maybe again we
have a snake eating a mouse you know be
a pretty you know a pretty
straightforward example or in this case
we have a duck eating a fish you know we
saw a moment ago a duck eating a frog
duck eating a fish we're getting higher
on the food chain here we have a herring
which is a type of bird eating a snake
so a snake itself can be fed upon by
even larger animals within the food
chain
and when we get to the fifth trophic
level though the quaternary consumer
quaternary is a word that means the
fourth consumer and so it feeds on the
level beneath it so the fourth consumer
feeds upon the third consumer and at
this point in the food chain again we're
pretty much looking at the top
carnivores the top omnivores within an
ecosystem these are what we call the
apex predators these are the Predators
that really don't have any predators of
themselves and so for instance a wolf
eating a rodent there's really not much
that hunts the wolf and unless you count
humans when we look at for instance the
bear and there's really not much that
hunts the bear unless we add humans to
this and lastly you got a lion eating a
buffalo you know the Lions are pretty
much at the top of the food chain in
their particular environment these would
be examples of the apex predators so
when we look at this particular food
chain if I were to give you this picture
and ask you what's wrong with this food
chain I hope you realize the arrows are
pointing the wrong direction it should
look like this and the reason we have
the arrows point in this direction if I
didn't make it clear earlier I
definitely want to stress it now the
arrows are supposed to show the
direction that energy flows the reason
the arrow is going from the mouse to the
snake because energy that was in the
mouse's body is being transferred to the
snake and that happens whenever the
snake eats the mouse so make sure you
guys are aware of which direction the
arrow is pointing it's pointing in the
direction that energy will flow okay we
we talked about decomposers briefly at
the beginning and one thing to mention
decomposes are rarely shown on a food
chain if I were to add a mushroom at the
very end of this food chain you know
right above the hawk that might give the
wrong impression that you know the the
mushroom hunts a hawk and though
obviously that's not the case but the
reason we don't often show decomposers
is because they really will feed on any
trophic level when that organism dies if
I add for instance some mushrooms over
here if I were to add the decomposers
then I would have Lions going from every
organism over to the decomposers because
when mice die their remains are fed upon
by the mushrooms when the grasshopper
dies its remains are fed upon by the
mushrooms and the other decomposers and
not just the dead or other dead bodies
but also maybe their waste their feces
may be fed upon by decomposing bacteria
and decomposing fungus and so I want to
mention the difference between the
detritivores and the sacrifice first of
all let's focus on the betrayal of ores
now this vulture right here is a good
example of a Detroit of or because it
will actually ingest and take bites out
of and feed upon dead matter like this
dead skunk right here it's feeding on
the dead remains same with this dung
beetle here the the beetle here is
feeding upon the remains of in this case
the poop from some other animal but
notice that between Avars actually
ingest they take into their body with
their mouth and they have a digestive
tract and they internally break down the
food when it's in their stomach and
those are the Detroit of ours and that's
different from the saprophyte mushrooms
and bacteria are good examples of
saprophyte because they release enzymes
onto whatever they are living upon they
will absorb nutrients from let's say
dead leaves or dead branches or even the
dead organism itself and they will
release enzymes to externally digest
whatever it is they are growing apart
here we have some mold that is absorbing
nutrients from the fruit so again what
the the sacrifice do is they externally
digest they release enzymes on the
outside of their bodies and these
enzymes will break down whatever they
are growing upon and then they can
absorb the nutrients through their cells
and that's how they they end up feeding
themselves but they're both types of
decomposers it's just how they decompose
is different from one another okay if we
focus on food webs you know here we have
a good example of a food web it's a
group of interrelated food chains you
know within this one single food web
there are probably dozens of different
pathways you could follow each pathway
would be a food chain for instance I've
highlighted this particular food chain
which is four trophic levels level 1
would be the grass level 2 of the
grasshopper level 3 the blue jay and
level 4 the hawk here we have one food
chain mixed into this food web here we
have another food chain of five excuse
me six trophic levels level 1 would be
the grass number two the grasshopper
number three of the spider number four
the squirrel number five the owl number
six the hawk here we have a completely
different food chain mixed into this
food web and one more here we have
another food chain highlighted in red of
six trophic levels the acorns level one
the grasshopper level two the spider
level three the blue jay level four the
cat level five the hawk level six
there's easily a few dozen pathways we
could take within this one single food
web but these are a lot more realistic
than a food chain and the reason they're
just more realistic is because they show
all the feeding relationships in a
community not just not just one single
single pathway in reality animals may
feed upon many different kinds of prey
not just one like is depicted in a food
chain well if I were to ask you to
highlight a food chain from this food
web and then label each of the trophic
levels you know that's something that
you know for instance here we might have
this from beginning to end starting with
a producer and going until there are no
more arrows here we have a food chain
made up of five trophic levels and then
labeling them I would label the acorns
the producers the grasshopper would be
the primary consumer the spider would be
the secondary consume where the squirrel
would be the tertiary consumer
and the hawk would be the quaternary
consumer using the vocabulary words that
we brought up earlier and one last
question you know what might happen if a
pesticide was used that killed all the
grasshoppers in this particular
community what side effects or
Consequences might that have well you
might start to see grass over growth
since there's no more grasshoppers to
keep the grass under control you might
see the slow death of spiders after all
they lost their food source you might
start to see a decline within the Blue
Jays the Blue Jays used to feed upon the
grasshoppers and because the spiders are
declining the Blue Jays are in trouble
for food you actually might see the
Hawks having to hunt more squirrels
after all if the Blue Jays are starting
to decline they have to find food
elsewhere so the point is you can see
how everything fits neatly within this
particular community and life exists
with them within a balance within our
food web if organisms are added and
removed that disrupts the balance that
exists within nature and so there you
have it energy within the ecosystems you
know if you're in my biology class try
answering these eight questions on a
separate sheet of paper
bring me your answers before school or
after school I'd love to check them for
accuracy thanks for watching